وهذه الصور المباشره اذا من صله القدوم في
ميناء جده الاسلامي حيث يتم استقبال رعايه
من الجنسيه الهنديه قادمين من ميناء
بورتسودان عبر سفينه هنديه حربيه يبلغ عدد
الذين تم اجلائهم اذن كما نشاهد هنا العدد
هو
293 شخصا نشاهد الان هم بداوا في الوصول
الى مطار او الى ميناء جده الاسلامي وقد
قامت السعوديه بتامين هذا الممر المائي
وتقديم الدعم والخدمات اللوجستيه حتى وصول
السفينه الى جده بامان نحن نتابع هذه
الصور ومن هناك من ميناء جده مع ان
مراسلنا هاني الصفيان هاني المزيد من
التفاصيل حول عمليات الاجلاء المستمره
التي ترعاها السعوديه من السودان
نعم اهلا بك صهيب واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه اذا مازلنا نواكب عمليه وصول
اجلام الرعايه من جنسيه متعدده والذين
يصلون الى السعوديه عبر اما قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه او كذلك قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه او ايضا هنا في ميناء جده
الاسلامي ولكن نتحدث اليوم عن وصول اول
رحله التجاريه او عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي
وهي السادسه بالنسبه للسفن التي وصلت
السعوديه طبعا هذه الرحله تحديدا نحن
نتحدث عن
من رعايه
الجنسيه الهنديه والتي قدمت او الذين
قدموا عبر السفينه حربيه
هنديه قدمت من بورتو السودان الى ميناء
جده الاسلامي السعوديه طبعا كانت في
تصريحاتها والبياناتها السابقه انها هي
هيئه ايضا ممرات مائيه ليب عدد من السفن
التي ترغب بنقل رعاياها الى مدينه جده
وبعد ذلك يتم استضافتهم وكذلك نقلهم عبر
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الجوي عبر الرحلات
الطيران طبعا هذه اللحظات الاولى من وصول
هذا العدد من الجنسيه الهنديه وعددهم
من المواطنين الهنديين والان تقوم ايضا
الجهات المعنيه الاخرى من وزاره الصحه
وكذلك نشاهد في الكاميرا الاخرى التي
ترصدها العربيه من خلال عمليات الكونترات
والمنصات التي وفرتها الجوازات السعوديه
حتى يتم انهاء اجراءاتهم في اقصى سرعه
طبعا في مثل هذه الحالات الان وفي عمليات
الاجراء او الاجراء العمليات الانسانيه
يتم عمليه اعطاهم بعض اللقاحات وكذلك
اجراء بعض الفحوصات الطبيه لا هو بعد ذلك
يتوجهون مباشره الى منصات الجائع والمنصات
الخاصه بنهاء اجراءاتهم وبعد ذلك يتم
نقلهم عبر الحافلات المخصصه الى مقرات
اقامتهم وبعد ذلك كيف سيتم عمليه ترتيب
مغادرتهم للسعوديه هاني
طبعا هناك الملحق السفاره الهنديه هي
موجوده والمندوب ايضا موجود وكان السفير
الهندي هنا موجود ايضا وحاضر في استقبال
ابناء جريدتي وكذلك يتم ايضا نقلهم الى
مقرات اقامتهم وايضا الى الفنادق المخصصه
لهم حيث يتم استعداد
الاستعداد اللازم بالنسبه لهم ويتم انهاء
اجراءاتهم بعد ذلك ومغادرتهم بشكل نهائي
الى بلدانهم طبعا هذه كما اوضحت ان هذه
الدفعه الاولى هناك ايضا دفعات سوف تليها
خلال الساعات القادمه ولكن من جنسيات
متعدده وعبر سفن السعوديه نعم صهيب شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه الصوره الحيه وصول وفد
من
الجاليه الهنديه الذين تم اجلائهم من
بورتسودان عبر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الى ميناء جده شكرا جزيلا لك هاني حتى
الان
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات